get ready to plug back in the matrix 4
has become one of the most hotly
anticipated movies of 2021 with less
than six months until the sequel comes
out
fans can't help but come up with
theories about how the film will pick up
where the matrix revolutions left off
it's all the more intriguing considering
neo and trinity died in the last movie
and yet both of the actors will return
in addition old and new faces alike will
join them as jada pinkett smith will
also reprise her role of niobe
at the same time reports indicate that
the cast will include jessica henwick
yahya abdul mateen ii
priyanka chopra christina ricci neil
patrick harris and jonathan groff
of course moviegoers may feel a bit
despondent realizing there is no word
that lawrence fishburne will return to
bring back morpheus
the character was an integral component
to the original matrix trilogy but it
would seem like this next installment
has moved past his influence
granted a surprise appearance is
possible and fishburn could merely be
playing coy about the true extent of his
role but for now here's what the
legendary actor has to say about his
future involvement with the matrix
franchise
in august 2020 he insisted that the
reason he wasn't returning to the
cyberpunk world was simple
i have not been invited reporters
obviously want any more information they
can get out of the actor but it's clear
fishburn doesn't have anything else
beyond that to say
doubt and disbelief
free your mind in promoting his upcoming
film the ice road fishburn sat down to
chat with jake hamilton of real blend
between discussions of which actors he
turns to for inspiration as well as what
he learned from director john singleton
hamilton brought up the matrix fishburne
didn't have much to say other than
i'm not involved you'll have to talk to
lana wachowski wachowski is a co-writer
and director for the upcoming science
fiction epic
and it sounds like whatever story she
came up with to return to this universe
didn't require the presence of neo's
one-time mentor and ally
hamilton remained persistent and toward
the end of the interview he again asked
fishburn for any information about his
involvement with any future matrix
properties
he's beginning to believe but again fish
burn remains stoically coy
the only thing i can tell you is that
lana wachowski can answer those
questions for you better than i can
wachowski has yet to comment on the lack
of morpheus for her next film but more
information will inevitably come to
light as the release date approaches
wherever long-awaited sequels exist fan
theories won't be too far behind
there's a ton of information to chew on
with the next matrix film however
anything we could think of for a future
installment remains an unlikely
possibility
screen rant reported on an intriguing
theory about how the matrix four could
follow neo and trinity as they traveled
to the past to recruit to young morpheus
played by yaya abdul mateen ii however
keanu reeves has gone on the record
saying the sequel will take place
after the events of the matrix
revolutions claiming no going in the
past it's another version a call to wake
up and it has some great action
all will be revealed so it's possible
that while neo and trinity find a way to
come back to life some time after the
last film morpheus met his demise and
stayed dead
such a plotline would be consistent with
what we've seen so far
as an assassin kills morpheus in the
matrix online game which sees the
freedom fighter following clues to
attempt to bring neo back to life
so such a storyline could end up
receiving a reference in the next movie
making it canon
however it still doesn't explain how neo
and trinity found a way to resurrect
themselves setting up additional
possibilities
after all we got this covered reports
that the matrix 4 could tee up a second
trilogy within the franchise
so even if lawrence fishburne isn't back
for this movie nothing says morpheus
couldn't return it a blaze of glory for
the next one
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the matrix series are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one